welcome to another famous friday i
believe that whatever goal you have
whatever
obstacles in front of you somebody has
already accomplished it and the fastest
way to reach your goal
is to model success find someone who's
already gone out and done that and apply
their strategies
to your business so today's lesson is
from pierre umityar
who is the founder of ebay and the
lesson is explore
so when pure media started ebay he was a
computer programmer he had a safe stable
job
he was a website designer on the side
freelancing way to make some extra money
and his girlfriend was an avid collector
of pez dispensers
she was a collector and she was
frustrated because she didn't have
anybody to
connect with who was also into pez
dispenser she didn't have anybody to
sell to
buy from trade with she would be part of
a community of other people
and she didn't know anybody who
collected pez dispensers so he said hey
why don't i build you a website
we'll build a website so that people can
connect over pez dispensers buy sell
trade meet each other
and and have a good time so we launched
ebay which is short for electronic bay
and this surprise people started signing
up people started buying selling trading
pez dispensers
and then other collectors started
joining as well people who wanted to buy
sell trade
barbie dolls and train sets and baseball
cards
started joining and he said hey this is
there's some value here right
i'm providing a valuable service to
people maybe i can make some money off
of it
and he started charging small fees and
he would make 25
cents 50 cents a dollar two dollars
offer these transactions and people
would
mail him checks thanking him for the
service and paying him the fee
and eventually got to the point where he
could quit his job where he could
hire people part-time and then full-time
and eventually becoming
ebay the you know multi-billion dollar
company making pierre
a billionaire himself but the point of
the story
is that you need to give yourself the
chance to explore
if you don't know what business to start
right peer media didn't start
ebay and become a billionaire by saying
this is the business i'm going to start
i know a certainty it's going to work
this is the big problem i'm solving
here we go bam right he had no idea
he fell into it because he allowed
himself the chance to explore so if you
don't know what business to start
if you don't know what company to get
out there and create you know you want
to be an entrepreneur but you don't know
where to start with it don't stress out
don't worry about having the perfect
plan right at the start
explore explore your interests explore
solving
major problems in your life explore
helping other people out
friends family do a pure media davis he
built a website for somebody right
how can you use your talents to help
other people
and then is there a way that that can
scale up right as you're helping people
as you're applying your talents as
they're getting value
can you apply that to a bigger audience
and provide even more value
that's the beginnings of a business if
you worry so much about getting the
perfect plan
right from the start you're probably
never going to start
because you never get that perfect plan
so if you don't know what you want to do
next
give yourself the creativity and the
time
to be able to explore and you might land
on your next billion dollar idea as well
believe those who watching like the
video to see more click the subscribe
button
thank you so much for watching i'll see
you soon
hi i'm thor rafzan from time management
evan carmichael's newsletter epic
subscribe